In this video, we'll import a Datasmith file into Unreal.
Now let's perform a brief exercise where we import our own .uDatasmith file into Unreal Engine.
If you open up today's project folder, you'll see two subfolders, one for the uProject file,
which will give you access to the Unreal Engine project,
and then the other one is an assets folder that gives you access to CAD files, Datasmith files, and DCC files.
So we open up the Datasmith file folder, we'll see that we have two .uDatasmith files in here,
as well as the assets that come with each of them.
In there, we see our .uDS mesh files, our .uDatasmith file in something like Notepad.
You'll see it's fairly readable, we see which program made this Datasmith file, right in a 3D in this case,
what version of Unreal it was originally made in, 4.27, as well as the various assets,
and then how they are going to be located in the scene, including additional data such as their light map values.
So now go ahead and back up into the uProject folder, and go ahead and open up today's project.
From here, we can take what we've learned, and go ahead to here, Datasmith file import,
and we can find assets, Datasmith files, and cumulusexp.uDatasmith.
When we open that up, it'll ask us where we want to put it, I'll put it in this temp folder,
and then it asks us what we want to bring in, geometry, materials, and textures, lights, cameras, animations, etc.
And then if we plan on baking lighting, we can have a min and max light map resolution.
If I do not plan on baking lighting, and if I do not intend to bake lighting and use Lumen,
I can uncheck generate light map UVs.
From here, I can go ahead and click import, and we'll see that not only is a scene created here,
but it is also automatically imported.
We can see also the hierarchy has been preserved from Rhino.
And if I wanted to adjust the origin of the whole project, for example moving the 200 cm up,
I could do that and everything follows along, and if I wanted to update the actors from the scene,
if I re-imported the file, I could do that.
Similarly, I could right click here and say re-import with new file, and go ahead and choose the cone option,
and we'll see an option here as well for respawn deleted actors if I had already made some adjustments here.
I'll leave everything as it is, press import, and we'll see the scene comes in, and it looks the same,
except now we have this cone on top, which is the difference between the first file and the second file.
If my original file had changed, I could just click re-import, and that would also update the scene as it was.
Also note the example map under content maps, modern house, we can save our scene here,
which is also an imported Datasmith scene file, as we can see right here.
Find it in our browser if we like.
However, because we no longer have the source of this file, we are unable to re-import it.
In the next video, we'll explore tessellation options when importing CAD data.